[Music]
the first time in my life i was aware of
the concept of fascism when was i was
about five years old and anybody who is
my age i'm 61 now will remember a series
called all our yesterdays which was like
world at war only very very boring um
the the only non-boring episode to be
honest was the one that i inadvertently
saw the first 10 seconds of which is the
one about the liberation of
bergen-belsen which was a concentration
camp liberated by the british in 1945.
my mum just just leapt up
which is unusual you know we're a very
sedentary family my mother leapt up
and just said we're not watching this
switched it off
um
she was half jewish and had spent uh
the war as a as a
war began when she was five years old
she knew because her relatives told her
that if we lost the war she would be
dead
um and what was interesting is that that
attitude which is which would seem very
alien to many of you that attitude
of people who had lived through the war
and knew about what we now call the
holocaust but did not call it then
they didn't want to talk about it even
even if they hadn't been primarily
affected you know she wasn't in that
sense of survivor
but
they didn't want to talk about what had
happened this was also true of
ex-service people my uncle got sunk in
the royal navy in the atlantic and
survived and never talked about it
there's a word we never talk about it
you hear that a lot in post-war society
but
at the root
the the kind of
as well as trauma as well as um
just wanting to get on with things
there was a logic bit to not talking
about what had happened and it was this
it can never happen again
um it was a one-off it was something to
do with the german character we don't
know what uh but it's been cured by you
know bombing their cities to smithereens
and rolling tanks over their country
and reorganizing it and um
yes it was to something to do with
psychology but how you know there don't
seem to be any hitler type people around
anymore so so what's the problem
around about that time
a historian called ernst nolte german
conservative became the
first serious writer to attempt a
history of three fascisms a comparative
history so nazism
mussolini's fascism and the fascism of a
failed right-wing group called action
francaise which was monarchic and
anti-semitic which failed in the sense
that it only succeeded when hitler
invaded france and some of them became
you know collaborator government uh type
people but it failed as a movement so
nalter writes fascism in its era its
title in british in english is
the three faces of fascism but the title
gives away the the assumption there was
a fascist era and it is over and it can
never happen again we've seen all
possible variants of it and so good now
we can study it because that's the ideal
position to be studying something when
it's a finished fact
that was the assumption of my of my
mother of my the people i grew up around
that was the assumption of the world i
grew up in
but round about the same time as nalter
was writing his book
french fascist maurice bardesh
spent his life denying the holocaust and
had been a nazi collaborator
bardesh wrote this
with another name
another face and with nothing which
betrays the projection from the past
with the form of a child we do not
recognize and the head of a young medusa
the order of sparta
will be reborn the order of sparta is
nazi speak for nazism
no unfortunately
he was right
we are living through the rebirth of a
new fascism and what i've tried to do in
the book is to explain what it is
why it's where it's coming from how it
thinks how the people who support it
think and how we might defeat it
people say to me when i kind of try and
you know get them to review this book
you know newspaper editors what's the
problem paul you know when trump's gone
you know sure tommy robinson once had a
million facebook followers and cadbury's
cream egg only had two million
uh but he you know he's been kicked off
facebook so what's the problem the
problem isn't that there are five or six
far-right groups in britain who get
about a hundred ins in the battley
by-election stood against each other
they all got a hundred patriotic
alternative for britain that's not the
problem
a bigger problem is that one in six
nearly one in five terror convicts in
british jails are nazis
um it is no longer the exclusive
preserve of irish republicanism and then
is islamic uh extremism it is no the far
right is is catching up
the reason why we don't hear a lot about
it is because they they rarely
perpetrate one guy
we don't know yet but the police have
not closed the book about the plymouth
mass shooter as to whether or not he was
an organized far-right member but the
ideologies which we'll we'll talk about
was clearly far right so there is that's
an annoyance another thing that's an
annoyance is if you're in my profession
i was filming on whitehall in in mid-19
in mid-2019 um
and was surrounded by tommy robinson's
supporters how did i know there were
tommy robinson supporters they were
singing oh tommy told me tommy told me
tommy robinson into my face
and as i film them you know
i realized for the first time in my life
they weren't just shouting about
something abstract they were shouting
paul mason marxist traitor to your
country we've researched you
so that's also a bit of a problem
but no none of these things are
earth-shattering i wouldn't get out of
bed and write a book about these things
if i was just worried about that what
i'm worried about is that a second
fascist era is possible and as badesh
suggested the fascism that we are seeing
has been regrown
from its original philosophical roots
which those of you who know about it and
about philosophy may know that we're
actually in the
pre-1914 period in the period of
nietzsche
bergson
scientific racism
houston stuart chamberlain the
scientific racist and oswald spengler
the the the the famous author of the
famous book bestseller the decline of
the west it is in that
philosophical ethos and from that
philosophical ethos that has emerged
a philosophical fascism and why is this
important because
if the the metaphor i use is that it's
regrown from its roots but in a
different greenhouse if you see what i
mean in the greenhouse of now in the
greenhouse of networked society
of
feminism which we'll come to and
climate change and
globalization
and so it can survive
in a way that the fascism that i fought
as an activist in the 1970s 80s and
early 90s in the anti-nazi league then
in a group called anti-fascist action
that fascism of the national front
combat 18 british national party
was in a way it was the old plant or to
switch metaphors it was like a tribute
band to nazism that's why it wasn't very
popular behind the scenes we all knew
that the leaders of the bmp had you know
posed with with swastikas in private
even if in public they flew the union
jack
uh
the other thing is and sometimes as an
activist as a white bloke with a
working-class accent one was designated
as being the person who would go and
stand in their bit of brick lane and not
in our bit so i stood next to them and
listened to them i have to say obnoxious
though they were those fascists were
rational people
they they they had a a rational if wrong
hatred of all the change going on around
them their dads and granddads had drank
in the same pubs they've been mostly ice
in the 30s their grandparents you know
the the pubs and boxing clubs of the
east end of london that's where they
came from and i could see i couldn't see
their point but i couldn't recognize a
kind of motivation today's fascism is
very different because in its regrowth
it has regrown around one form of
behavior that you will see time and
again from the capitol hill uh
insurrection from
bolsonaro's uh mass support in brazil
right through that right the way through
to
the extreme parts of the anti-vax
movement here
which is what i call performative
self-deception
these are people who no longer believe
science their own eyes and ears hannah
arendt said this and i quoted in the
book hannah aaron writing about nazism
said
as they create their lying world they
have to create a logic that follows
their where everything they only believe
she says their imagination and not their
eyes and ears because their imagination
can summon up something consistent
whereas their eyes and ears provide
contradictory things they can't get
their heads around and it is that
new fascism that i want to just spend a
little bit of time uh anatomizing in the
book there's a whole chapter of case
studies about the way that modern
fascism uses symbolic violence to tell a
story what they're doing when they're
going on a mass shooting spree as in the
as in the christchurch new zealand mass
shooting at two mosques or when they
simply stage uh demonstrations in favor
of the right armed demonstrations in
favor of the right to catch covid as
they've been doing all across america um
they're trying to tell a story and what
i want to try and leave you with more
than anything else apart from the last
bit which is what we do
is an understanding of what that story
is
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas
you